première observation le flou et
l'incertitude règne encore à quelques
jours de la rentrée souhaité par le
gouvernement dans le premier degré à
l'heure où nous parlons
aucune école de martinique ne sera prêt
à recevoir d'enfants dès le 11 mai
ensuite selon les estimations seulement
10 à 30 % des parents envisagerait de
confier leurs enfants à l'éducation
nationale pour le moment sur cette base
trois grandes catégories de communes
semble se dessiner les municipalités
opposé à une reprise avant septembre
sont les premiers à être montré au
créneau
c'est le cas des communes de sainte
marie du robert de schoelcher du
gros-morne d'ajouts pas bouillon et du
morne vert qui compte à elle seule près
d'une cinquantaine d'écoles d'autres
communes comme basse pointe saint joseph
ou trinité s'oriente également vers une
non l'ouverture des écoles même si
certains maires se réservent encore la
possibilité davies et au besoin une
nuance enfin avec le françois qui
gardera ses douze écoles fermées jusqu'à
septembre mais qui réservera une classe
par école pour des rencontres
pédagogiques
parmi les municipalités qui ne se sont
pas encore prononcés on trouve le
lamentin et ses seize écoles ainsi que
le morne rouge faute de matériel grosse
surprise la commune de case-pilote qui
était en pointe
concernant la réouverture fait désormais
partie des indécis et dans tous les cas
n'ouvrira pas dès le 11 mai comme
annoncé initialement
troisième catégorie les municipalités
qui met en oeuvre les conditions de
reprise de quelques écoles courant mai
ou juin
on y trouve la ville de fort de france
qui détient un record d'une cinquantaine
d'écoles et qui a opté pour une
pré-rentrée 100 élèves le 11 mai avec
des ouvertures possibles au cas par cas
ultérieurement dès le 18 mai les
communes du saint-esprit et du lorrain
devrait ouvrir les portes de leur école
d'autres communes ne fixe pas de date
mais affiche la volonté d'ouvrir
certains établissements avant septembre
c'est le cas de saint pierre sainte luce
et trois idées qui accueille 10
des enfants de soignants attention dans
la liste de ces communes susceptibles
d'ouvrir des écoles avant septembre
les garderies du matin et du soir en
dehors des cours ne serait pas assurée a
priori